okay so if we're
taking a utilitarian perspective on
ethics
we're focused on pleasure and pain
primarily
remember utilitarianism as a version of
hedonism
we're interested in making evaluations
moral evaluations are when you say
something is good or bad right or wrong
just or unjust even to some extent if
you say something is noble
or base you know certain things that we
might consider
aesthetic also can be moral
say somebody has a beautiful character
or an ugly character right that's that's
still talking about moral issues
so when we're doing that we want to look
at at some point in the semester so this
is the day when we're going to start
explicitly doing this we want to look at
what are we actually evaluating and then
why
and i started with action on the board
because
if you think about the way
many people carry out moral evaluation
and also the way that professional codes
a lot of you have have majors
that have some sort of professional code
if any of you are in psychology
sociology business
has anybody pre-med or
you know looking at nursing anything
along these lines going
maybe pre-law they all have codes codes
of ethics
and you can go online and you can find
them right anybody doing social work
there's a social worker's coding
ethics and those things always have to
tell you about
actions you can do this you can't do
that
for instance if you're a lawyer what's
something that you
shouldn't do
yeah uh what are they called an
attorney-client confidentiality
you're right and so if you actually get
a legal ethics textbook and lawyers
actually
in law school have to take a legal
ethics class
they'll talk about not bringing
confidentiality it's a bad thing to do
it's focused on the action just the
action itself
it's not focused on other things they
say
do this don't do that what's something a
lawyer should do
let's say a defense attorney what should
they do
yeah fighting tooth and now for their
client
yeah um generally in legal ethics book
it's not put quite so
colorfully but that's a good way to put
it right they're usually framing it in
terms of like provide the
best defense possible for for your
client but you're right yeah fight tooth
and nail
and that's prescribing a kind of action
um a certain motive action if you're
a doctor think about you guys are all
familiar with the hypocritical
um what is one of the things that says
that you shouldn't do as a doctor
like really broad strokes
yeah not supposed to just like you see
somebody like on the side of the street
like suffering
like a kind of crazy enough to just
drive past them yeah
um doctors have a higher
moral obligation that ordinary people to
take care of
they find injured some states have
things like good samaritan laws and
those
you know prescribe behavior too right if
you good samaritan law means if you're
driving and you see somebody
laying on the side of the road you're
supposed to stop and check on them
call 911 or something like that the
doctor should actually like take care of
them
so that's that's an action it's not
saying
why the doctor it's not saying what
consequences should come out of it
it's just saying they should do this
now if we want to think about why we say
certain actions are really bad
what do we usually focus on what's the
what do actions produce
constant yeah we often think of two
different terms of
say consequences and in our ordinary
life we often talk about that when
they're negative right
if you do this there's going to be
consequences that's
what we say uh and a more neutral term
is outcomes
we talk about good outcomes or bad
outcomes um
and so often we evaluate an action by
saying well it's a good action because
it produces good consequences
why should you know the doctors stop and
take care of somebody
because you know they might save their
life it makes sense
right why should the doctor not just
pass by and said going you know i've got
i'm really busy i've got a dinner
engagement
because i would have bad consequences
that's on the
front end that's that's what happens
from from the action
what leads to an action
there's more to moral decision making
than just acting right
do you just suddenly do things decision
making
yeah um let's put something here
we'll just call it like there's a moment
where you actually
choose and your choice
may lead to the action taking place it
may not lead to the action taking place
but generally we hold people responsible
for the choices
uh and what goes into your decision
making process what's further here on
the back end
yeah the situation well
let's all these things could be part of
the situation
um yeah desire very good
um and we can frame this in terms
sometimes of
intention where we talk about
motive and the desire
may be just to do that kind of action
like if you're
if you walk down the hall whistling and
i go after you and i say why are you
whistling
give me a justification for your action
you may you know look at me like i'm
crazy and say
i just like to whistle you know i don't
know why i was
doing it leave me alone dr saller right
because that would be kind of a strange
thing to ask you about if if you like
throw a cup of coffee at somebody and
walk out of the huff
and then i you know walk up to you in
the hall and i said why did you do that
that would make a lot more sense for me
to be
asking about your motivation wouldn't it
um there are some actions we just do
because we just like doing those actions
i i tend to hum or whistle or tap my
feet or things like that i have no idea
why i do that
but it just happens you know you may
have other habits like that
there's a lot of things that we do
because we have desires or intentions
and this may come out of the situation
itself
you're thrown in a particular situation
some of your desires now become
active some of them become engaged
and the desires are often to produce
certain consequences aren't they
you make friends with somebody at first
not because you actually like them
but because you're gonna be stuck with
them
your roommates and um you can either be
friendly or unfriendly
and how's the semester going to go if
you're unfriendly
compared to being friendly yeah
it's it's probably going to be a lot you
know uh
less pleasant for you so you know the
consequence you could choose the
consequence and that could be
part of your desire and we can evaluate
somebody on all these bases
now let's go back to the lawyer thing
the defense attorney
who breaks
confidentiality that's a bad
action the legal code says you shouldn't
do that
why does it say that well you could
frame that in terms of consequences
it screws things up for the system
people don't trust their lawyers then
they're not going to
get a good defense because they're not
going to reveal everything to them
you could also frame it in terms of
intention why did this person break
confidentiality
did they do it because um
their uh client is a serial killer
and just revealed where all the other
bodies are that might be a good time to
break confidentiality right
it can solve you know 20 other murders
where the parents are worried where the
children are
i would bring confidentiality in that
case myself
that was ethical in my legal system
legally ethical meaning fitting the code
of legal ethics
yeah you could get in trouble for it
probably would end up happening
is they would make when they decide the
case
they would look at the intention
and they would evaluate it no longer
just in terms of the legal code but in
terms of
moral issues as well because legal codes
very often don't very well embody
moral codes that's why we make arguments
this
should go this way instead of this way
um
if you think about a different legal
code like the ten commandments this is a
great example
for this the ten commandments as such
just prescribe certain kinds of actions
right
there's 10 10 classes of action and
you know some of them are what you
should what you're supposed to do on
on the sabbath and how you're supposed
to conduct yourself in a religious
setting
and then there's the ones that have to
do with um neighbors
and they have things like don't kill
people right
translators don't kill or don't murder
and i suppose it makes a difference how
do you do that
don't commit adultery don't steal don't
bear false witness
honor your mother and father those are
just prescribing certain kinds of
actions so if you want to say as a
person a good person or a bad person
and you're only using those those rules
do they follow the rules or do they not
follow the rules do they commit those
kind of actions or other kinds of
actions
now if you look at the setting of it if
you look at the context
let's say we take the one about false
witness
now you know how often are you in a case
where you
have to worry about bearing false
witness right
a lot of you involved in trials right
now
it would sound like it's just about
trials right
yeah that's that's now notice we're
saying
at that point it's not just about one
specific kind of action it's being
understood to
encompass a whole other range of actions
how do you know that
well if you read around you know in the
old testament the new testament you find
it it actually says
don't do this this is what bear and
false witness means
right but then it gets a little bit
broader
why shouldn't you bear false words
i mean you know let's say you're not
convinced that you should follow that
code
let's say i don't think it's bad i don't
think it's wrong
why is lying wrong why why
is it bad it leads to bad consequences
quite often doesn't it
what are some bad consequences
you lie to somebody how do they look at
you
why it's a liar and then what happens
next time
you want them to leave you yeah you can
ruin your reputation
oftentimes when we lie we lie to try to
get advantage
or to get out of something that you know
we shouldn't get out
what kind of person are you going to
become if you keep lying over and over
again there'll be consequences for you
with your your own character right
and we can also ask about the intention
are all lies
equally bad maybe actually some lies are
good
you know talk about
you know innocent lies the the boyfriend
you know the old famous example the
boyfriend who's asked
by the girlfriend is placed in the
impossible situation do i look fat in
this dress
right what can you answer is there any
good answer to that
that would be um you've all seen the
abraham lincoln
one right where abraham lincoln kind of
deliberates about it he says yes you do
i can't tell why um yeah i mean telling
the truth is good
but you're also if you tell the truth
maybe you're hurting their feelings
or the truth might be no you look right
in the trust too but then oftentimes
they're not believed
what i want to hear it's an impossible
situation
um best thing is to just extricate
extricate yourself from
the question are there other cases where
you probably should lie
if the serial killer is knocking on the
door and says
i want to kill your mom where is she
right now
should you tell him where your mom is i
would tell him the exact
opposite direction myself wouldn't you
what do you think that's about
intentions
it's the same action right lying
maybe the intention could be could be
good or bad
if we take a different sort of thing
with the kind of things that show up in
dramas or in plays
where somebody lies to another person to
try to make them jealous
or to get them into conflict with
another person is that a good intention
i mean if you really like conflict i
suppose like this but
most of us would probably say no right
now different moral theories are going
to focus on different aspects of this
more
kant who we're going to look at in a
couple weeks he focuses almost
exclusively on this he says
i don't care what the consequences are
what i care about
is the action itself and especially your
intention
as a matter of fact it's not even enough
to do the right thing
you've got to do it for the right reason
you've got to do it because you
you know you place duty above
happiness or desire or or satisfying
your inclinations
that's one way to look at that yeah is
this similar to like the
does the mean justify the end again
or is it that could fit in here um
bentham would say the the ends
you're thinking the ends justify the
means because the means
are like yeah means couldn't justify the
ends that would really be
strange to think about but anyway yeah
bentham
and utilitarians are going to focus
almost exclusively on consequences right
actions are not going to be good or bad
in and of themselves
like lying for example is the lie going
to have good outcomes
or bad outcomes that's the question that
bentham would ask
whereas confident say lying is wrong
it's always going to be a bad thing to
do
there's a big difference between moral
theories on this this sort of thing
um what consequences you're looking for
might vary too like you know if you're
thrusymicus and power is what's
important to you does this
increase your power does this give you
domination over other people that would
be the consequence you like
does this allow other people to have
power over you that'd be the consequence
you don't like right
if you're bent them what are you
interested in
what are the key things
and the consequences that you care about
we'll start with the same letter yeah
pleasure in pain right
for for a utilitarian everything boils
down to
is this going to produce more pleasure
than pain
overall this is what he calls the
greatest happiness principle or the
utility
principle is it going to result in
better outcomes or worse outcomes
for everybody concerned everybody is an
aggregate
individual so the action it's important
to look at actions it's also important
to look at
desires and motivations it's even
important to look at
things that he calls dispositions
or we would call them tablets right
and those
lead to certain actions that come from
certain motives
a person is greedy that's a certain
disposition if a person is generous
that's another disposition if a person
is kind that's a disposition if a person
is cruel
that's a disposition those are who they
are
part of their character right
so what we're going to look at today is
how you evaluate good and bad
from a utilitarian perspective and we're
looking
at this stuff over here
dispositions intentions motives
but you notice that for bentham they're
always evaluated ultimately in terms of
the consequences that they bring about
and not just any consequences but pain
and pleasure
i think that makes it very simple to
work with very simple to wrap your head
around
ultimately like he says for instance
intentions
um an intention could be a good or bad
intention
depending on one of two things
the consequences it produces or the
consequences it's intended to produce
or the motive behind it that's it
that's all you have for for deciding for
jeremy bentham
that makes for a pretty simple way of
deciding moral issues right
if you want to decide whether somebody's
intention is good or bad
look at the consequences that they were
trying to bring about
or look at the motive that you can tell
the structuring
let's look at
what he says about
the acts in general a few
things i'd like to say about bentham um
before we go into that it's things that
i think may help you when you're when
you're reading him
one is as you've been reading through
bentham i think you've all noticed he
likes lists
doesn't he he likes to enumerate things
there's lots of numbers and it's not
just
calculations he gives you these catalogs
of different motives or
possibilities or pains or pleasures why
do you think he does that
it makes for really boring reading
doesn't it bentham is a dull
person to read if you're finding him
boring that's okay
i find it boring to read he's worth
reading
because of what he's saying but he but
the way he frames it is very boring
why does he come up with all these lists
of things
maybe you like it i don't know maybe
some of you are really into lists
why do you think he's doing that
what do you do when you come up with
lists
like a to-do list
it's organizational very good yeah
sometimes when you actually put things
down on paper you realize which things
overlap with each other
or oh i've already got this on there i
don't have to put this one down
why else do you make lists
you can think of to-do lists or like if
you're packing for a trip
you might make a list like a checklist
yeah like as you go through you can like
check
things off like um after you finish them
and it kind of like i don't know i
crossed something off my checklist it
feels like
good like or something yeah i do too
actually that's
one reason why i have to do this so that
um
although i never get any cut but it
feels good to get some things done at
least
um and sometimes i'll keep to-do lists
around after their
their expiration date just like i said
i've actually done something
and maybe bentham had some sort of
motive like that when he was writing it
you know i assume that he enjoys
writing otherwise why do i do it
there's another motive though if you
think about a checklist
you put together a checklist why do you
put together
that checklist
exactly so you don't forget so you can
cover everything
you know when i go on trips i almost
invariably forget
at least one thing maybe a toothbrush
maybe i mean sometimes it can be serious
like i
forget my phone um
i've never forgotten the tickets but
that's you know
it wouldn't be any trip bentham is
trying to be
comprehensive he's trying to cover
everything to show that utilitarianism
can actually address
all of this so that's one aspect of
his writing that i think you want to be
clued into another aspect that i suppose
i can apologize for a little bit
if you notice his diction the words that
he picks are not words that we
ordinarily use we've talked about this
before
with a few other authors he's a
victorian writer
so he uses some some words that
you may have had to go to the dictionary
to look up um and after you did
you realize that it was probably kind of
a waste of time because they were very
easy to express
in our language like one of one of the
ones that i like in particular is
licoriceness which we're going to look
at later
a child can be licorice what is that
well it means that they you know they
enjoy candy
you know we say somebody has a sweet
tooth
bentham also has some assumptions that
are rather victorious
about pains and pleasures i don't know
if you've noticed this when you went
through
there's certain pleasures that he
highlights
and certain other ones that he sort of
downplays and
maybe as we go through if you see which
ones
point that out it's kind of an
interesting thing to think about
the other thing is you notice he also
talks a lot about punishment for this in
this section right
why do you think you talk so much about
punishment is he into that sort of thing
was he you know is he somebody who got
his
pleasure through somebody else's pain
like he was into s
m or you know something along those
lines
does that jide with you know the way he
talks about other things probably not
right
he's not the marquis assad somebody
who's actually not that far from bentham
in time
actually so why do you think you talk so
much about punishment
there's a historical connection here
anybody have any ideas where do we
punish people the most
where does that become a big issue
it's not coming to mind because none of
you spent a lot of time in there
we're in this context what's up prison
prisons are one place where punishment
is supposed to be carried out right
penitentiary is a place where somebody
is supposed to be penitential they're
supposed to be
atoning for what they've done done wrong
a prison is a punishment that we give to
people you know
do this sort of thing 25 to life um
how do you get to prison
yeah okay so
we have prisons this is an end point
and then one has to what's the
connection what has to happen in between
for somebody who commits crimes to end
up in prison
there's a trial and some sort of
procedure the police are involved in
some way
so the justice system bentham was very
concerned
with the british
justice system and the prisons as a
matter of fact he was a prison reformer
and the british legal code at that time
was very punitive
you could get very high penalties for
very small
crimes and the judges did not did not
appear to be particularly interested
in why you had committed the crime so if
you
if you've robbed somebody because you
had to
find medicine for your children or keep
your children from starving or something
like that
judges didn't care they would still give
you the same
you know pretty high penalty as as other
people and oftentimes the penalties were
capital
you know there was a lot of
crimes that were punishable by death at
that time so bentham was a legal
performer
that's part of the background behind
this that's why he's so interested in
intention
in motive and disposition and that's why
he talks about punishment so much
because if you're sentencing somebody
you want to know
why they did what they did what their
state of mind
is or was and what kind of person they
are
if you think that they can be reformed
do you give them a bigger punishment or
a smaller punishment
what do you think
there was a guy recently there was a big
case where a judge
ordered a husband who
had been arrested for domestic
abuse to take his wife
out to dinner to talk to her
and a few other things yeah
why did the judge say why did you know
was the judge
crazy or did he have some reason for
that
well it turned out that i mean domestic
abuse can cover a lot of stuff
right just like sex crimes um if you're
on the
sex offender registry it could be that
you're a hardcore child molester
you know which is at one extreme could
be that
when you were 17 you had sex with a 16
year old
and you you know you got in trouble for
well it would be 18 and
16 statutory rape or something like that
and the parents press charges
those are all within the same continuum
it's the same thing with domestic
violence you know in this case the cops
got
called and the judge determined that
really not
you know nothing had really taken place
nothing substantive that had something
to do with who this guy
was and the nature of their relationship
he thought well this guy he's got some
problems and one of his but he also
ordered him into anger management right
um one of the big problems was this guy
wouldn't listen to his wife about
anything so then they get to
get to fighting and so he wanted to
change his behavior he wanted to change
his actions
to produce better consequences so he
gave him a very light sentence and then
he said of course if you don't do this
you're going to jail
so he threatened him with a stiffer
consequence would he have done that say
to somebody who you know
has been in court five times for beating
his wife
hopefully not no no slap on the wrist
for that guy
because if you want to change that
person's mindset it's going to take a
much bigger punishment
right so the
the kind of person that one is the state
of mind that one has the intentions the
motives that one has
that that is important for determining
um
what kind of punishment to apply so
bentham is very focused on that
now i'm going to jump right into his
discussion about intentions
and the the key theme you're going to
see coming up over and over again
with this what makes an intention
what makes a motive what makes a
disposition right or wrong good or bad
ultimately it's about consequences so he
says over and over and over again
you know there's there's two things that
this looks to
one is this the other is consequences
and then when you ever
look at whatever this is this this that
always turns out to be about
consequences too
so when it comes to intention he says
you can look to the motive of the
intention he says
a man's intention on any occasion may be
styled good or bad
with reference either to the
consequences or to his motives
if it be deemed good or bad in any sense
it must be either because it is deemed
to be productive of good or bad
consequences pleasure or pain to other
people
or because it is deemed to originate
from a good or bad motive so if we want
to understand
what's going on over here and say this
is good or bad
you have a good motive or a bad motive
then you have to think in terms
either of the consequences
or we have to think in terms of
something you know intention
things in terms of motive what is motive
ultimately going to be about though
consequences so we can look at
everything
in terms of good or bad consequences
pleasure or pain
so what what are the sort of intentions
that that we could
have he goes on a little bit further and
he says
if you want to talk about an intention
as being a good one
you have to look at what the person was
trying to achieve
sometimes we do act and we didn't
actually realize
that they were going to have bad
consequences sometimes we actually do
bad
we do things that we think are going to
be bad but they turn out to have good
consequences
um and that's good
but the intention could be could be bad
right
what would be a case where you do
something
good that you think it's good but it
turns out badly
like have you ever said something to
somebody when you're trying to make them
feel better you actually made them feel
worse
maybe you know you revealed some
information and you thought this might
help
them you know oh i can relate to you
and then you know you reveal something
in the process about maybe a friendship
that they have
or something a relative of theirs has
said about them
and now they they feel even worse right
that has bad consequences um
your intention itself though was what
you were trying to attain
right and the intention was not the
value of that intention was not just
these consequences it's the ideal
consequences you were trying to
to achieve make the person feel better
what would be an example
can you think of any where you wanted to
do something
that would have bad consequences but it
turned out good
you wanted to make somebody feel they
had but you ended up making them feel
good
as a result
i can think of one it still does involve
some pain
don't even know people who like to fight
like to argue
yes maybe some of your roommates like
that
yes no so you
let's say you're on opposite ends of the
political spectrum you know
um you find something they're a big
whoever supporter well we'll pick
somebody who's dropped out of the
presidential race
they were a big um michelle bachman
supporter right
and you find something out on the net
that's that's supposed to you know be
disparaging about her
and you bring it up to them you say see
you're going to vote for a crazy person
and you're trying to get a ride on them
right what you're trying to do is
produce pain
aren't you you're trying to hurt them
um who knows for what reason maybe you
like doing that
or they did it to you at one time you're
trying to get revenge
or you think that this will you know
somehow get them to be a better roommate
or whatever but it turns out that they
rise to the occasion and they say i'm so
glad you brought that up
i've been wanting to talk with somebody
about that and they
you know they get into an argument with
you and now they're actually
happy because they're a person who likes
to argue
is that what you intended so was your
intention a good
good intention you had good consequences
was is your intention a good intention
no because you wanted to bring about
pain for somebody else
but pleasure for yourself to probably if
you're we're trying to just get a rise
up
so like it says to warrant the speaking
of the intention as being a good one
it's sufficient if the consequences of
the act had they proved what to the
agent they seemed to be
would have been of a beneficial nature
now he says
going down a little bit more if you want
to understand
um an intention you want to go beyond
just looking at the consequences or the
intended consequences
what else do you have to look at here's
where he brings up another term
motive and this is what we're going to
talk a lot about today because bentham
focuses very
seriously here's the first thing to get
it
get in your head when it comes to
intentions
all of you have intentions for every
single act that you do
right your intention is your intention
if we both engage in some sort of action
together
we could be said to have you know share
some sort of intention
but really my intention is something
that i have your intention is something
that you have
and sometimes these could be at you know
odds with each other or they get
different
you know if we decide to
go to the store you know you may go
along
with the intention of passing some time
i may go along
with the intention of buying some piece
of hardware that i need
we don't always have to share the same
intentions our intentions are
we might stay personal they are
individual
motives are things that we all share in
general
and we can talk about human motives as
being sort of constants of human nature
now the motives may be stronger or
weaker in each of us but we all
more or less predict them have the same
basic
human makeup so we all share the same
basic motives we all share the same
basic
structure of motivation is what
psychologists call it
so he says
how do how do we think of motives well
if you're a utilitarian
what are your motives what is it that
you actually
desire what is it that you
want to produce
we had it just a moment ago pleasure
right
every motive that you have is either for
bentham is either to attain some sort of
pleasure
or to avoid some sort of pain that makes
sense doesn't it
if you're a utilitarian because pleasure
is a good
like he says pleasure is in itself a
good uh even setting aside immunity from
pain the only good
pain is itself in evil and indeed
without an exception the only evil or
else the words good and evil have no
meaning so motives are actually
pleasures
and pains of one form or another
let's look at what he sets out then as
these different motives
and i'm not going to assume that you
have a long
the reading selection which is what i'm
taking this stuff from
let's look at these different
motives
and you're going to notice something
along the way as we go through this
so he talks about um
of sense
what are pleasures of sense you know
seeing hearing smelling tasting
so you know you all like to eat certain
things i like to drink
coffee that's a pleasure for me
what's something i don't like to drink
glasstop
don't like that that that soy milk stuff
it's kind of weird texture for
me maybe some of you like that right
produce that it doesn't really produce
pain but it's certainly not a pleasant
problem
so we are motivated quite often by
wanting to attain certain pleasures why
did i go
and buy myself some coffee in part
because i wanted to you know be awake
and alert but
i already had some coffee this morning
did i actually need to go and buy
another
cup of coffee i like to drink coffee
when i'm giving a lecture i like to have
that pleasure
of taste every so often that makes the
day
nicer for me i think all of you can
relate to this right
why did you pick the clothes that you're
wearing right now i think most of you
are wearing comfortable clothes right
a few a few of you have dressed up a
little bit in that case
it was not maybe it's comfort but maybe
it's also a different sense
a sense of
good if it's not the sense of say touch
you know comfortable clothes
why else do we wear the things that we
wear because they
of sight they they look good right um as
a matter of fact this
whole fashion industry that we we have
and erin is a big fashion school
what's it focused on is it just about
making comfortable clothes
they're not comfortable
yeah i think high fashion quite often
doesn't um
nor are they durable or things like that
but they look good don't they
and people like that that's a that's a
motive
satisfying our appetites for
sexual desires um so he says in in
particular to the pleasures of taster
palette corresponds a motive
and this could be um
you know this could be looked at in a
good sense or it could be looked at on
advanced we have good words for this we
have bad words for this
if we call it hunger is that a good word
neutral right somebody's hungry you're
not saying he's a good or bad person
what if you call somebody uh voracious
or gluttonous is that good or bad
it's bad right because one of the seven
deadly sins
eight capital vices that the seven
deadly sins came from
um but notice it's the same motive for
jeremy bentham
he gives you some examples he says a boy
who does not want for victims that means
a
kid's not starving steals a cake out of
a pastry cook shop
and eats it in this case how would you
evaluate his motive it's a bad one right
he did something
bad he produced some pain for someone he
produced some pleasure for himself but
he produced pain for the pastry chef
if it be asked what it is it may be
answered perhaps
licorice meaning that the kid likes
sweet things
a boy buys a cake out of a pastry cook
shop and eats it
what's his motive now is it good or is
it bad
it's really neither he says
unless unless his master be out of humor
with him this is the case in which
the boy is an apprentice then it may
then perhaps you may call it
licoriceness as before
in both cases his motive this is the key
point his motive is the same
what is his motive getting that pleasure
so you can't actually say for that
motive whether it's good or bad
in itself you have to look at the
circumstances you have to look at the
consequences that it produces
if it produces good consequences it's
good it produces bad consequences it's
bad
then he talks about the pleasures of the
sexual sense that's kind of funny
to talk about that right do we have this
do we have a sexual
sense bentham apparently thought we're
good
and he says this corresponds the motive
which in a neutral sense may be termed
sexual desire
and again if you say sexual desire is
that a good word or a bad word
neither right in a bad sense it's spoken
of under the name of lasciviousness a
variety of other names of reprobation
and we don't say that sydney's
as we say a whole bunch of other things
right we're not going to go into those
because
you know he's going to go on youtube
but you can think of all the words that
we use right think of words that we use
to describe
somebody if we want to be negative about
them
who indulges themselves too much in that
in that respect
can we talk about this in any good
senses
we're going to talk about somebody
having a healthy healthy libido
right
this is neither good nor bad in itself
again this depends on
the consequences he uses the example
there of
two people have sex right and
in one case the man is um
you see he says radish and he means
raping raping something
that's bad right why because it's
producing
pain overall it's producing pleasure for
the person who's doing it but it's
producing more pain than pleasure so
it's bad
um now they they're married and
not the same people um same example two
people having sex
they're married both of them want to now
it's it's good
or bentham says at least not bad which
is perhaps an expression of this
victorianism
so once again the motive is the motive
good or bad
we have to look at the consequences he
talks about
another thing that we desire wealth
he calls it your interest do we have bad
names for somebody who's motivated by
the desire
for wealth or do we have bad names for
that desire itself
that's a person who hoards well they
they do have a desire for it
and it leads them just to hold on to it
um but what do we call somebody who
just wants to get everything for
themselves yeah well there's like gold
diggers which are people who go after
rich people to get
there well gold diggers yeah that's
that's that's a good example
um there's all sorts of words like that
you had your hand up too
you're inside gold diggers too no
greedy yeah he talks about avarice right
we don't use that word we talk about
greed
greed is a desire for wealth it's a
desire for
possessions and he gives
some examples he also says in other
cases
you might call it economy frugality
industry that sounds pretty good doesn't
it
let's look at a few of the cases that he
brings up for money you gratify a man's
hatred
by putting his adversary to death to
become a contract killer
for money you plow his field for him
it's the same motive isn't it the motive
is
wealth what's different what makes it a
good or bad
action what makes the motive good or bad
in this case
the consequences if you're killing
somebody those are bad consequences
right if you're plowing a field that's
not great consequences but it's
certainly not bad consequences
what else does he talk about um
and we have a different word for that
these days what do we call that
very good french
yeah um this can be looked at
as good or bad as well um in a neutral
sense it may be termed the desire of
ingratiating one's self
in a bad sense what do we what do we
call people
he talks about servility we i think we
have other names for that sort of thing
what what do we talk ab when we look at
somebody
who's being too friendly because they
really you can tell they really want
people to like them and there's
something kind of unhealthy about it
do you have any words for that sort of
thing for that kind of
motive
a suck-up you know i think we have a lot
of words for this sort of thing
that's this desire that's this motive at
work
for a kind of pleasure that that people
want
um if it's looked at being as a good
thing
then we often call it sympathy or
benevolence
and look at the examples that he gives
again it says to acquire the affections
of a woman before marriage
to preserve them afterwards you do
everything that is consistent with other
duties to make her happy
is that good or bad that sounds pretty
good doesn't it
it's a class mostly composed of women
what do you think about that
do you think do you think that assuming
you want to get married
a guy should in order to acquire your
affections
and preserve them afterwards do
everything that is consistent with other
duties to make you happy
is that what you want that make you that
give you pleasure
that's a good motive right
for the same purpose you poison a woman
with whom she is at enmity
in this case he says your motive is not
just bad it's abominable
do people sometimes ask things of others
in relationships okay if you're really
my friend
you'll do this remember all those those
movies
do you have to watch those movies when
you're in in elementary school in high
school about peer pressure these days
if you like us you'll do drugs if you
want to be cool you'll
shoplift what were yours about
that's what ours were about oh heaven
sounds different right
um premarital sex that was a big thing
when i was a kid what are you what were
your movies about
with peer pressure yeah
you know and the basic idea is
you know what is peer pressure it's
wanting to fit in with other people it's
wanting to be
friends right so it could be good or it
could be bad
depending on what what it motivates you
to do
he also talks about having a good name
or reputation
um he says
it may be styled the love of reputation
in particular cases it's style the love
of glory
and he uses another term for it that
actually
interestingly enough we've mentioned
seven deadly sins before
is there one that would correspond to
this
pride all right vanity um
it could be a good thing to want a good
good reputation though right
do all of you want to have a good
reputation i think so we all have these
these motives working in us
is it going to lead you to do good
things or bad things that's the question
that bentham is
is posing i'm going to skip over
his examples then he brings up another
one
power we actually do get pleasure out of
power
out of having power we get pleasure out
of
the mere thought of having power
we don't like other people exercising
power over us do we
he says um to the pleasure that power
corresponds the motive which in a
neutral sense may be
termed the love of power people who are
out of humor with it people who don't
like it what do they call it the lust
for power the
or we might say the desire to dominate
other people
where did we talk about this before in
this class remember
a character who associated with this
particularly
a couple weeks back as a young man
who wasn't he said you ought to do that
that's the whole goal of life is to have
power over other people
yeah thrasymac is very good um
thrasymachus was motivated solely by
this
you know he was motivated solely by that
he also didn't want people like him
i think he talked about pleasures but he
wanted power and he wanted other people
to
to give it to him
let's see i'm going to skip over the
religious sanction
and um he talks about sympathy as well
and this is an interesting one
he doesn't mean sympathy in the sense of
like somebody
gets hurt or dies until you send you
know a card or flowers or you know you
say my condolences or something like
that
he means sympathy in the sense of
feeling for another person so it's
broader than that it would include that
right
but it would also include
caring about how they feel in general
so somebody retires do you throw a good
party for them
that would be a question of whether for
bentham you're a sympathetic person or
not
you know if you say ah screw i'm not
gonna have to see them anymore they're
retired
you're probably not a sympathetic person
you don't really care about how they
if you do that you know i mean
if you actually do throw a nice party
for them and you say ah we're gonna miss
you
all that sort of stuff you probably are
a sympathetic person
another term that he uses here is
benevolence
and
what is what is benevolence um
is that a term we use a lot these days
we have benevolent societies like you
know
the fireman's benevolent society
what does that mean that's a good term
to clarify
early on you're benevolent
yeah are you terrible or generous yeah i
think those would be aspects of
being charitable or generous that's very
good
it comes from the latin terms better
meaning good
and um we get volition
from uh volumes being of good will
towards other people
you know in general being motivated by
the good of other people so benevolent
person is the kind of person who wants
to see other people do well
and take steps to make sure that they do
not because
they're getting anything specifically
out of it themselves but because
they actually like to see other people
do well they take pleasure in that
bentham thinks that's one of the best
pleasures we can get
so he gives a couple examples of this
could that itself go bad
here's a really interesting example
a man who has set a town on fire is
apprehended and committed out of regard
or compassion for him
you decide to help him break out a
prison
in this case the generality of people
will probably scarcely know whether to
condemn your motive
or to applaud it i mean on the one hand
this guy burned down
a town that's a bad thing right
on the other hand he's also a human
being
you know you don't want him to be in
prison so you help break him out of
prison
but let's say maybe he he's learned his
lesson too he's not going to burn down
any more talents
right um terrible thing i'll never do it
again
is that a good or a bad motive that
one's pretty hard to tell isn't it
but benevolence could lead you to do
that sort of thing
you see actually if you if you watch
some of these um
high profile cases you see some people
who want to give everybody the benefit
of the doubt that could be benevolence
the man is taken again and put on trial
use to save him you swear
falsely in his favor so you lie on the
stand
now it's a little bit easier to say nah
that's benevolence but that's not a good
motive in this case
you detect a statesman in receiving
bribes out of regard to the public
interest
you give information and prosecute it it
says in this case by all who acknowledge
your conduct who originated from this
motive
your motive will be deemed a lawful one
in style public spirit
so doing things for your community doing
things for your country
that could be benevolence at all what's
another pleasure
that we have
so fine ambulance is wishing good to
people
for their own sake what do you think
mullet wants us
yeah doing doing you know you're
actually probably doing bad things to
other people
um you know what are some examples of
this that you can think of
everyone talks about bullying these days
right a bully is a malevolent person
they are motivated by the desire to to
make somebody else feel pain
that's why you bully people also i
supposed to have a sense of
power right it could also be you know
friendship you want other people to like
you so you know you pick on
the kid that everyone else picks on but
quite often
uh people are motivated by beloved ones
what are other forms this could take
cruelty you know you see some kids
most kids go through a period where they
hurt animals
i don't know if you guys know this or
not if
when you were a kid if you pulled the
wings off of flies
or you pull grasshoppers apart that's
okay
you're not crazy you're not you know
liable to
be you know a very cruel person or even
a serial killer later on
if you were torturing dogs and cats when
you were 12 years old
there's probably something seriously
wrong right
do you know kids like that they're
motivated by
a genuine desire for malevolence
people do in fact vent them is you know
just talking about what human nature is
like people do in fact take a pleasure
in inflicting pain on other beings
this is part of the human makeup
actually uh
you know infants go through this they
call it infant sadism
um they do things like you know when i
was a kid
i remember
like going up to my ad and just
hitting him one time you know just to
see what would he have
you know and i thought that was kind of
strange when i reflected on it
and then i noticed that you know like my
uh my kids will do that
every once in a while they'll just like
because you know i'm big and so they
know i can take it i think
part of that's part of it we're kind of
feeling wrestle and stuff like that
but every once in a while my son will
just like uh i'll be laying on the bed
and he'll jump on me
right um is he doing that because he
just wants to wrestle and that's part of
our friendship
no he's he's a human being we are
predator
animals we actually do have this side of
us
the key is to you know not make that the
whole court that's what the
person who's a sadist or a bullying
now he also talks about pains as being
motives
so we can be motivated by certain kinds
of pains
he talks about the the wish for
self-preservation
the desire of preserving oneself from
the pain or evil or
death and question
and he says that there's there's a lot
of bad names for this
you know if you're on the battlefield
and you act on the motive of wanting to
avoid pain
what do we call that if you run away
from the battle
deserting and call a deserter a
very good so he talks about cowardice in
these cases
we have fear of all sorts of things
he says if you want to put in a good
sense you could call this prudence
and remember we encountered prudence
before in terms of
wisdom so we also want to
avoid
pains that's one of our motives and he
gives some examples of these
um to save yourselves from to save
yourself from being hanged
imprisoned or fined you poison the only
person you can give evidence against
that's a motive that some people follow
right in this case your motive will be
styled abominable
but what made you do that
self-preservation
so is self-preservation necessarily good
or necessarily bad
it really depends on the circumstances
doesn't it
to put an end to the pain of hunger you
steal a loaf of bread
are people going to condemn you for that
what do you think
what do you think would you condemn
somebody for who's
starving for stealing a loaf of bread
would it change it at all if they you
know
they break into the store and instead of
you know taking the first
loaf of bread they can find they go in
the back and find themselves in gourmet
bread
would that change your opinion of it at
all probably no it wouldn't
because bread is bread okay
he says to save yourself from drowning
here's here's a topic
to save yourself from drowning you beat
off an innocent man who's got a hold of
the same plank
in this case what is your motive
self-preservation
is it is it good or bad well it's bad
that you know another human being
dies but you're also preserving your own
life maybe that that
guy would do the same thing
to save your life from a gang of robbers
you kill them in the conflict
is that a good thing or a bad thing most
people would look at that as
a good thing right what do we call that
self-defense a soldier is sent out
against the party the weaker
set out on upon a party against a weaker
party of the enemy
before he gets up with them to save his
life he runs away
self-preservation again but that's
that's a bad one right that's cowardness
um what else do we have what other kinds
of pains do we
avoid we want to
avoid trouble being troubled by things
he talks about a love of ease a desire
of avoiding trouble
we call it sometimes indolence
we don't actually use that term what do
we call somebody in our society
who is motivated just by the
desire to sort of avoid work or avoid
having to take pains when we call
something like that
somebody doesn't do much because
they like to lazy we call it laziness
yeah that can be a motive sloth which is
another
classic term for it right um like it
says to save the trouble of taking care
of it a parent leaves his child to
perish
in this case everyone's gonna say that's
a terrible moment right
is that is that any reason to abandon a
child i feel like taking care of them
that's the same motive though as he says
a mechanic in order to save his labor
makes an improvement in his machinery
it's the same desire to avoid work
to avoid having to take care of things
but it's a good moment now listen
we say ah this is an inventor you know
this person is an entrepreneur this
person is uh
contributing to mankind so he says it
appears there's no such thing as any
sort of motive which is a bad one
in itself or consequently any such thing
as a sort of motive which is exclusively
a good one
so how do we evaluate moments then well
he gives you
one way to do it you can look at
all these motives are they mostly
oriented towards pleasing the self
or are they mostly oriented towards
society
and let's let's think about some of
these uh malevolence
definitely not oriented towards pleasing
society right
that's you know you want to hurt
somebody because it makes you feel good
that's going to be bad
what will be good what would motivate a
person in general
to do good things this one's easy
they like helping other people they like
making other people happy
a person who's motivated by that is
going to do good things
right what else do you think would would
best make a person do the right thing
help other people yeah
you're right that's the second one that
bentham
talks about he says this is the best one
this is the most reliable one the second
most reliable one is
good name reputation it could go bad
right we've looked at some circumstances
um
are there any other ones that are
generally good yeah
friendship yeah again third one that
bentham talks about
in general i mean you could have bad
friends right you could get in with a
group of people who themselves have bad
motives and they could steer you the
wrong way but in general wanting people
to like you
how do you get people to like you by not
acting like a jerk
by not contributing to their pains by
contributing to their pleasure
right so that's pretty reliable
he talks also about religion i didn't
put that up there because
that can get more complicated he says
this is definitely
going to be a bad one
are there any other ones that are
neutral or indifferent but
quite often can steer us the wrong way
well
what do people do for wealth
that can steer us the wrong way pretty
easily can't it
what about you know sensual pleasure sex
desire for sex can that get people into
trouble
you see it all the time this is what we
make movies about
self-preservation neither a good thing
nor a bad thing right
we saw that it can lead you to do
terrible things it can also lead you to
do
good things what about love and power
is that necessarily a bad thing it could
be a good thing
he says this method of arrangement is
not
perfect and the nomenclature is not that
good
so he says we should look at these in
terms of the influence they appear to
have on the interests of the other
members of the community
laying those of the party itself on
question so we call them
social dissocial and self-regard
and so the ones that we circle like
sympathy
good will love of reputation uh
friendship those are what he calls
social motives
those are the kind of motives that lead
us to live
well together with other people in
society because we're looking at their
pains and pleasures more than just our
own
our pleasures are actually oriented
towards
doing right by them towards producing
more pleasure than pain for them
um displeasure you know if you are a
person who really likes hurting other
people
you're not going to be very well
socialized aren't you you're not going
to be somebody
who you necessarily want in society
that's going to be much more
self-regarded
or that's going to be just social and
self-regarding you know
why do we have to watch out for the
desire for wealth or the desire for sex
or the desire for
you know sexual pleasures or the desire
for self-preservation why do we have to
watch out for those
because those have much more to do with
our own pleasure and pain
and much less to do with other people so
they will tend to
lead us to disregard other people's
pleasure and pain
and to favor our own in the process why
would this be bad from utilitarian
perspective
remember utilitarianism says pleasure
and pain are good but we even want to
look at everybody's
not just our own we're no longer
epicurus or aerostimus
we're looking at everybody concerned so
if what really motivates you is
sexual desire or a desire to please your
senses
or solve preservation you probably are
not going to be
a reliable agent in bringing about other
people's happiness
so from the utilitarian perspective
we're not going to be particularly good
motives in general
so now if we want to think about
dispositions
what is a disposition it's different
than a moment
so
if you think about a disposition we talk
about character traits
we talk about somebody being the same
kind of person over time
so you know what are some examples of
dispositions that people have
what are some traits that you like about
people
what do you want in them or a friend
we talked about this you know a couple
weeks ago what are some of the things
you like
yeah being trustworthy okay i think what
say again being loyal those are those
are
almost part of the same sort of package
i would say
let's let's start with that what might
get them to be
trustworthy or loyal i mean that means
that they're going to act the same way
over over time
could this motivate them to behave in
that way
i think so um friendship certainly could
couldn't it maybe love of reputation or
good name
um could be a motive to being
trustworthy
you want people to think of you in a
certain way so you can think of yourself
in a certain way
um these other ones are probably not
going to be great motives for getting
somebody to be trusted whether you're
loyal
you know if it's just about sexual
pleasure and if somebody is trustworthy
or loyal only because they're getting
sexual pleasure out of it
as soon as the sexual pleasure starts to
go away or
become you know less interesting
there goes the loyalty right and we call
that fidelity
in that case um
self-preservation is probably not going
to make you a trustworthy person
wanting to avoid work is that going to
make you a trustworthy person
probably not what would be an example of
somebody
a trait that you don't like in something
yeah a thief okay very good
um which of these
do you think is probably the most likely
motive for somebody to be a thief
of power wealth yeah why would you say
power
how do you think all the power of goes
together
i suppose in a sense they could bentham
distinguishes between the pleasures that
come with them but they are you right
you can you can buy power
with wealth walk into a restaurant you
suddenly have power because you can
pay somebody um might a thief be
motivated by other things like say
friendship
yeah maybe if all their friends are
thieves right um
if they're in some weird kind of society
where having a good name depends on
being a really good thief
i suppose that could fit in um i think
self-preservation
is falling like the classic if you were
starving
i think so too yeah um what about
malevolence there's some people that
are mean and they'll steal things from
other people not because they get
anything out of it but
just to screw them over i think so yeah
um so we've got all these different
possible motives for these these
character traits
and um
so when we get dispositions
we can't count on a disposition
necessarily having
just one motive we have to look at the
person
we have to see what their actual
structure of motivations are
bentham says some really interesting
things about both
here and this is going to apply i think
not just to bentham's own philosophy but
this will also fit in when we look at
other philosophies that stress
dispositions like virtues he says
is there nothing about a man that may be
properly turned good or bad
when on such or such an occasion he
suffers himself to be governed by such
and such a motive
yes certainly his disposition now
disposition is a kind of fictitious
entity he says
feigned for the convenience of discourse
in order to express
what there is supposed to be permanent
in a man's frame of mind
when on such and such an occasion he's
been influenced by such and such a
motive to engage in an act
we attribute dispositions to people we
could be wrong about them right
you could think that somebody is a mean
person when actually they're a kind
person they just had a bad day you only
saw them on that one day when they were
actually
very frustrated and they they talk to
you in a mean way
but we attribute dispositions to people
and we say that they have them
and that they're part of who they are he
says
how are we going to evaluate this it is
with disposition as with everything else
it will be good or bad according to
what its effects according to the
effects it has
in augmenting or diminishing the
happiness of the community
so who's involved in the community
everyone right and yourself
like he says uh a man's disposition may
be considered in two points of view
according to the influence it has either
on
his own happiness by the way you know
the gender of specific languages
goes for the women too right or
everybody else's happiness
so if you want to decide whether a
disposition character trait is good or
bad
you look at the effects that it has on
on happiness
does it make people happier more sadder
and then he says um
we can talk about somebody having a
mischievous or we would just probably
say bad
disposition when by the influence of no
matter what motives
he is presumed to be more apt to engage
or form intentions of engaging in acts
which are apparently of a pernicious
tendency
that means acts that are going to bring
about unhappiness
if somebody is the kind of person
who will in general act
or intend to act in such a way as to
produce
more harm than than good
then they're a bad person that's a bad
disposition according to
them if on the other hand they have a
tendency to
act or to you know to form the intention
of the acting
in such ways that that produce more
happiness that produce more
good than harm for people then they have
a what he calls a beneficial tendency a
meritorious or a beneficent disposition
so he talks about
evaluating means how can what can it
boil down to
you have to look at the motives
to have a disposition he says is to
where is that the disposition is to
allow yourself to be influenced by
certain motives
let's look at one of the examples that
he uses
he talks about the tendency of an act
being good and the motive
being self-regarded in this case
you can't tell whether somebody has a
good disposition or a bad disposition so
baker sells his bread to a hungry man
who asked for
does that mean the baker is a good
person
do they have a good disposition why is
the baker selling the bread
what is their motive right so they have
a desire for wealth
the other person has a desire to eat
it's not really a good disposition it's
not a bad disposition right
um where the tendency of the act is bad
and the motive is of the self-regarding
kind a man steals bread out of a baker's
shop
let's say that he he's motivated by
getting the bread for nothing he's
motivated by
wealth himself he's not starving he's
not trying to feed his
you know hungry children or something
like that does that show a good
disposition or a bad disposition or
a neutral one it's a bad disposition
right because the act is
in general a bad act and the motive
is a self-regard
uh where the tendency of the act is good
and the motive is pure is the purely
social one of good will
a baker gives a poor man a loaf of bread
his motive is compassion a name that's
given to benevolence
he wants the person to no longer be
hungry
is this a sign of a good disposition or
a bad disposition or a neutral
good good disposition right he's a
generous person he's a beneficent person
bentham gives you a whole bunch of
examples he also talks about cases where
the tendency of the act is bad
and the motive could be the purely
social one of good will
and he says this this sounds a little
strange doesn't it bad act
but you're motivated by benevolence
could that could you think of cases
where that might work um
he says if we want to understand that
we've got to think of benevolence
in terms of narrow benevolence and then
wide
open so this is something we're thinking
of for a moment
can you be can you feel this can you
have this desire for this only towards a
certain group of people
people who are like you um americans
fellow poughkeepsians fellow marist
students and then say
screw everyone else i don't care about
their happiness i care about my group's
happiness your family
yeah yeah i would just thought like kind
of let me get there
yeah i mean in a certain sense
i mean if you look at the literature of
nazi germany
germans were supposed to be good to each
other
and they were it wasn't just towards
jews
they were pretty much they saw
themselves as having a right to be bad
towards pretty much everybody else even
their own allies
you know they worked with the italians
but italians aren't really as good as
the germans
that would fit the bill a family in
which everybody is very loving towards
each other
and then hostile towards everybody else
or preys on everybody else
that would be an example of narrow
benevolence
wider benevolence would encompass
everybody
the whole community so he talks about an
example of this
no this is nothing like the nazi example
i want to stress a man with a numerous
family of children
on the point of starving goes into a
baker's shop
steals a loaf divides it all among the
children
reserving none of it for himself
is his motive
and is his disposition a good one
or a bad one it certainly is a
benevolent one right he's taking care of
his children
he wants the children to be be well he
wants them to be happy he wants them to
have pleasure
not pain he's doing an act that's bad
but it's probably not going to produce
that much displeasure to the baker
compared to the pleasure that's being
produced for the children
it's still narrow uh benevolence he says
it would be hard to infer that the man's
disposition is abandoned
now change the case give him only one
child
but a child who's in no imminent danger
of starving
so changing it on one end and let the
man set fire to a house full of people
for the sake of stealing money out of it
to buy the bread with
now you're talking about a bad
disposition right
about a bad outcome and bad motives
um so like he says
i'm going to skip on a little bit
it's evident the nature of a man's
disposition must depend on the nature of
the motives that he's have to be
influenced by
so ask yourself which of these are you
more influenced by
in general in the course of your life
and then think about other people
which of these influence people more
there are probably some people who are
more motivated by
than evidence right
i think you know some do you know some
other people who seem to be mostly
motivated by
all levels mean people
yeah no
maybe in just plays or movies or
cartoons or
stuff like that i mean i know a lot of
people are
quite mean like that um
so like it says the disposition is as it
were the sum of the intentions
um and the intentions are formed by the
motives
some of these motives he calls um
i'll put these words up some of these
motives he calls
that will erase this
or what he calls
kind of a funny word
seducing means it's going to lead you to
doing something bad
it doesn't mean it 100 percent every
single case
but in general if you're motivated by
seducing motives if those have a
stronger
role in your makeup and your psyche if
those are behind your dispositions
you're probably going to
do bad things more often than good
things
tuna larry a tutor does what with you
they help you in what way
they help you to study they help you
become better educated helps inform you
so he talks about seducing or he also
calls these corrupting motives
and these can also be called
preservatory or
preserving motives and he says there's
no sort of motive by which a man may not
be prompted to engage in acts that are
of a mischievous nature so every single
motive
could be bad in one way or another
depending on its outcome
but are there some motives that you can
rely on
consistently to be leading people
towards the good
what's the number one thing for him that
we had on the board before
because there's pick one
to plant in human beings yeah or
our bananas
uh provided it's you know broadcast
right
if that was the only thing we had in our
nature we'd always get along wouldn't we
i think you can probably figure out that
one of the worst corrupting motives is
going to be
well that's right if you allow yourself
to be primarily focused on hurting other
people
from a utilitarian perspective you're
going to be a bad person
no ifs and you know answer buts about it
you may on occasion you know help people
out like you know
you you kill my enemy because you didn't
like him yourself
and maybe that helps me out but you're
not doing it because you're a good
person
right you're doing it do you like
hurting people
what are other ones that you think would
steer people towards
in general doing good things
your reputation yeah love of reputation
or
um becomes a good game
uh we you know if you care about what
people think of you
then you know that in general if you
behave like a jerk
people are going to look at you like a
jerk and call you a jerk you're probably
not going to act like a jerk if you know
that
to get people to like you you actually
generally have to
do good things for them contribute to
their pleasure
if you want the good name you'll
probably do that right
is that as reliable as this this one
as a motive could this one go bad
yeah um so it's less of a
tutelary moment but it's still pretty
good what's another one
yeah i would say under seducing i would
say power
the desire for power
um but what's another one that would fit
under two delays
another thing that tends to in general
the desire for a certain kind of
pleasure that tends to make us
being wild towards other people
thank you appreciate very good
um
these are the ones that he talks about
he also you know considers a few other
ones
what else could be what else could be
um seducing rules yeah
well yeah i think that he
he thinks that quite often if that's
your main thing that's driving you
you're you're probably going to in
general
produce less happiness than than
than happiness more unhappiness than
happiness
more pain than pleasure you'll produce
more pleasure for yourself
because you know it's a self-centered
motive so is power
um i mean it would be interesting to
think about
the sex drive with respect to this
bentham would definitely like place it
over here
but he's pretty victorian in that way
maybe
you know i mean it does lead to
relationships quite often
maybe it's somewhere in between here
right maybe the pleasures of sense also
fit in there
he also talks about some of these
motives
often being seducing but sometimes in an
artificial way being tutelary
like self-preservation for example
self-preservation that can get people to
do
good things if you set things up right
or the love of ease
sometimes that could could be a
tutorial but in general it's going to be
these
um so he says
if we want to think about a person's
character
whether they have a good character or a
bad character
we have to look at which of these are
stronger for them
when they get thrown into and you talked
about situations of temptation
what goes on when you're having a
temptation
you have desires that are contradictory
right
otherwise if you only had one desire you
wouldn't have any problem
when you're tempted you generally want
to do something good but you also want
to do something bad
so let's think about for example the
temptation
of going after wealth
but doing it in such a way as to ruin
your reputation
other things that you could do for money
that would get you a bad reputation
a whole bunch of them right uh i think
you probably think of
uh many different examples of this
um producing a sex tape yeah
um that is like you know
cost people their pageant title in some
cases
i don't know that they actually did it
for wealth usually it was like well kim
kardashian did
you're right yeah in her case
and i don't know that she's ever really
motivated my good name
she certainly wants a celebrity but i
don't know that anybody
i don't know that anybody sees her is
like wanting to project being a really
good person
what's what's the the saying that
any oh any publicity is good publicity
yeah i think that people who think that
this is kind of just a side note i think
people who actually believe that
have a mistake and understanding of what
good men can say i agree with that
because a lot of some people actually do
believe they choose that as like an
excuse
yeah there's a difference between having
a good reputation and just being famous
you know i mean charles manson is famous
he doesn't have a good reputation
he's infamous actually turns out to be
famous in a terrible way when it comes
down to it to sum all of this up
for utilitarianism we've looked at
how you can evaluate actions how you
could evaluate
states of affairs or policies things
like that now what we've looked at today
is how you would evaluate a person's
personality or character or their
structure of motivation
what makes them act the way that they do
and so you see that from a utilitarian
perspective what does it always boil
down to
what are the two p words
pleasure and pain and it's not just
one's own pleasure and pain it's it's
everybody's concerned and you know it
can have circuits as routes i mean with
intention you can say
well it's the consequences pleasure and
pain or the motive
but then what does the motive boil down
to does it produce pleasure or pain
with dispositions it's the motive again
some of these motives are generally good
motives or bad motives
but why are these good motives because
they lead to producing pleasure not just
for yourself but for other people in
general
and why are these in general bad motives
because they tend to produce pleasure
just for yourself at the expense of
other people's pleasure
or at the cost of other people's pain
that's pretty much it for for
quantitative utilitarianism
this is this is bentham's system
so if you wrap your head around that
which does take a little time
it is i had been a little bit impeded by
the fact that bentham is very boring to
read
did you guys find that lots and lots of
lists
lots of victorian language but if you
wrap your head around it
you see it's a very powerful moral
theory
it's not one that i myself actually
hold that you know
is my theory but i can certainly see the
value of it it allows you to design
things very easily doesn't it
you can always look at pain and pleasure
which is generated which is
which is taking place which is being
produced
which is predominating that's one very
easy way to decide
um things from a utilitarian perspective
so that that's where we'll lead them
along and have a good weekend